hello everybody and welcome to part 4 of
let's play lacasa the amnesia custom
story alright um for some reason when I
left the game before it didn't save my
game so I had to relive everything one
more time so that was fun
alright anyway I got a key to something
and now I'm moving forward also um I
didn't use as nearly as much oil when I
went through it again so I've got more
oil that's a good thing alright um it's
a key to the main hall wherever that is
I'm all cave-ins ok ok alright we're
gonna hear anything nope okay here's
another chemical nothing else nothing
else okay
alright Oh Oh what's up oh [ __ ] that get
get out of here get out of here oh man
oh
all right even trying to blow through
the first part quickly again it was it
fun and that thing was chasing me it was
not fun all right
okay went down that way glass oh must be
oh good golly
Oh No oh not the tomb the lab was
somewhere I almost fell I read that
why does it have to be the tomb or the
morgue oh it's always someplace bad
always bad
alright alright okay
I'm okay alright dead end shouldn't lit
that one alright what do we get here oh
boy oh boy
I don't like this a bunch of convoluted
hallways with no clear direction sure
you're useless Timmy
more tinderbox sanity potion Gordon I
hope you aren't offended but I've gone
ahead to the lower levels of the temple
with guides Carmy Leone Leone
the roots of the quiz Oh blossom bleep
down I expect to find our biggest
harvest yet oh yeah it might even be too
much for our little team of people to
handle yeah no kidding Carmelo and I
unfortunately discovered the hard way
that carrying cure scient I can have
some adverse side-effects oh boy Nadja
anxiety paranoia and possibly even
hysteria of exposed for long periods
yeah some cure-all rendezvous back with
you tomorrow morning by the entrance be
safe don't trigger any Aztec booby traps
wait I thought I thought this was how so
African not South American whatever
historical inaccuracies aside um all
right
Gordon freeze man I wonder if that's
freeze Minh all right bang oh shut up it
would it can break a giant wall of rocks
I'm sure can break an iron block hey
what do we get here oh that's that's a
good sign
Oh No Oh No rotting flesh it's another
monster aah
oh why would I want to open it why would
I want to open it why am I so damn
curious ha boy all right man this is
convoluted I don't know where I am I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know where I'm going boy
oh this is the other side of that gate
Oh what are these tombs sarcophagi I
don't like any of them ha what done
uh-huh no no no I refuse okay all right
okay all the slowest opening drawer
locker cabinet ever Oh what's this
corpses corpses in here ah oh oh
all right who wants some huh
who's up oh oh there goes oh you're gone
that's what I thought
yeah boy yeah yeah laughs laughs laughs
okay all right that's nowhere oh oh let
me out of here oh I want out of here Oh
any more oil okay okay I'm okay
oh boy oh goodness gravy okay blocked
huh no monsters yet oh this is a key to
that the door oh boy the door oh boy
who's in here who wants some all green
gas makes my head hurt ah then
surprising being here ah Oh dead guy
bottle of blood phenomenal ah oh no no
no no no no oh did I close the door I
didn't close the door today don't come
here don't come here don't don't you
dare oh I will a [ __ ] I was smack the
[ __ ] out of you if you come around this
corner don't give me out here well give
me how do you give me out of the are you
okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay
right hiding right behind me I don't
know
the lab with some wearable as well do
these two pairs not my lab though oh
yeah here yeah you don't even don't even
think about it oh oh oh oh did I did I
get
[Music]
how did I get good why I needed I got
three chemicals
Oh Oh oooh I do
[Music]
main chamber of this area what area okay
maybe it was I think I got that note
back here in this me oh yeah the main
chamber key okay
Oh
oh he made a choice he could have just
walked on by he could have but he didn't
okay all right I'm okay closing for the
door god all right it could've been it
maybe come on give me something don't
make me go back in the tomb this was the
main chamber there was a key and
everything oh maybe it was just a kid
didn't I don't know I don't know I
didn't read that note when I got it what
was back here
nothing oh man I'm getting out of here
why can't I mix it in the laboratory it
must be in the laboratory that's why
it's a laboratory
it's got good stuff to mix chemicals in
I think maybe I don't know
there's gotta be something
Oh Oh there we go okay all right we're
good okay there we go
oh man I was dumb I was a little dumb
there sorry about that guys sorry for
being stupid okay volatile mixture all
right Oh
get me out of here Oh get me out of here
ah Oh No take cover in the closet oh oh
hello
hey Joyce all right get me out of here
Oh give me out here oh okay Oh red
carpets nothing nothing
fire going see no door to close
oh I don't look crystal clear but my
visions kind of not so good okay okay
uh-huh
what was it was it collapse oh clock
again did I forget to set my alarm
oh it's um rusty key okay I don't look
so good saying he's okay but I'm not
doing so good
all right why did I come in there why
did I need that key seriously why why
did I need the key why I have a bad
feeling
why is there no music playing wait a
minute wait a minute this is not
familiar what's going on this is the
room I started in Oh
oh dear Lord oh boy oh my rabbit get out
of here get out of here
no large push in the oil i what am i
doing i have my thing on oh okay
i have to cut it here come on guys stop
so I don't have to come all the way back
so thank you guys so much for watching
I'll see you guys in part five I think
five all right thanks so much for
watching bye bye